[Musique]
pourrais tu m'expliquer ce qu'est
l'adolescence
non je pourrais pas parce que c'est très
simple c'est très très très imprécis
pour moi c'est très une période très
difficile
il ya des moments où on est dans une
très grande joie et puis d'autres on a
des cafards sans savoir pourquoi comme
ça c'est enfin c'est un changement entre
entre l'enfance et les adultes
cc c'est inexplicable de l'essence aussi
on peut expliquer les adultes et ont
expliqué les enfants il a damé faire
comprennent pas mais on peut pas c'est
vraiment chaque jour ça change je crois
que ceci encore enfin et parfois du coup
c'est très rare on réfléchit plus en
plus d'usagers
et puis d'autres fois on a des petites
crises de folie on redevient
complètement fort jouent à la marelle
enfin des trucs comme ça c'est très
varié 800 une enfant ou une adulte je me
sens bien je me sens rien
je sens une enfant ni dadu je crois que
je vais prendre mes responsabilités mais
pas comme une adulte et je réagis pas
que trop comme une enfant je suis bien
je pense tout d'abord il ya une chose
que l'adolescence des garçons des filles
ne serait pas la même façon et ne se
passe pas au même moment je pense que
une fille devient adolescente avant un
garçon ça va très bien un second stage à
tétouan au g13 on comprend qu'il n'est
pas d'accord on a dans l'adolescence
pain et acheteurs qu'à la japon la
saison fut hélas elle a complètement
changé le plus de trois ans alors mes
parents l'acceptent pas tellement alors
comme moi je pense que aussi dans deux
trois ans si j'ai complètement changé
j'ai pas tellement pressé est-ce que tu
découvres à cet âge là toi
tout ce qu'on n'a pas découvert est
enfin c'est à dire toutes les
responsabilités qu'on peut avoir
des joies conte qui nous était interdite
quand on était plus petit parce que quel
joueur vous avant d'avoir des amis des
garçons qui sont je crois que c'est très
important aussi à cet âge là et d'avoir
des contacts avec les garçons et que
qu'on ne pouvait pas avoir est un petit
parce qu'on comprenait on comprenait pas
c'est une source de joie
oui mais la recherche de ce garçon quand
il n'existe pas c'est pas ça qui est une
source de conflit pour l'adolescent
c'est difficile parce qu'en général les
garçons vers 15-16 ans essaye de
s'amuser plutôt avec les filles et les
traite un peu comme des choix alors que
les filles elles sont beaucoup plus
sérieuse et elle essaye de de chercher
vraiment est une affection beaucoup plus
profonde et ce moment là les filles sont
très déçus par les garçons qui skie
vraiment se moque d'elle
et si c'est difficile de trouver ces
garçons bon moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord indique annie ma camarade tout
à l'heure les garçons ne pensent qu'à
s'amuser avec les filles c'est assez
vrai tandis que je sais pas moi je peux
pas juger mais je pense que les filles
prennent beaucoup plus sérieux
je pense qu'il a tout à fait raison des
garçons deux filles et justement pour
nous sa création près enfin j'espère
qu'on m'a personnellement si ça qui me
donne le plus souvent le cafard et puis
enfin je cherche je m'entends va-t-elle
vous tellement avec mes parents alors je
cherche autre chose dehors et je le
trouve pas et je trouve que les parents
je crois pas qu'ils peuvent voulu
comprendre
à très bientôt je pense pas et
d'ailleurs qui nous comprennent mais
parce que ils sont quand même un peu en
retard ils sont pas du tout c'est pas la
même génération
donc ça n'a pas de rapport j'ai pas du
tout de problème avec mes parents fait
avec ma mère et je pense que elle est
très jeune d'esprit parce qu'elle essaye
de me donner tout ce qui lui a été
retiré quand elle était jeune
tout ce que tout ce dont l'a privée elle
essaye de nous de nous en faire profiter
nous et je peux tout lui dire je peux
parler avec elle sans aucun problème je
me confie certes surtout pas mes parents
je confirme mes frères j'ai des grands
frères s'amène surtout ensuite l'eau
seulement pour moi simplement j'ai envie
de dire mon mot je n'écoute plus mes
parents me thézan pour pas être à
solange envie de dire ce que je pense et
puis le dis je le dis ça ne plaît pas
mes parents je comprends pourquoi ça ne
leur plaît pas
j l'adolescence mais je l'avais
différemment de mes parents parce que
moi j'ai envie de vivre ma vie je
l'avais sont les adultes qu'ils soient
tous les mois ils vivent pas leur vie
ils subissent leur vie je pense que
entre générations de génération en
génération il ya quand même une
évolution des adultes nous on ne sera
pas les mêmes adultes que nos parents et
enfin j'espère surtout pour le sera pas
et on aura des différences commencera
peut-être pas des différences
fondamentales mais il y aura quelque
chose de différent et petit à petit on
arrivera peut-être à la ville de touba
idéal mais je suis pas tellement
d'accord parce que en à l'heure de
penser que les adultes qui sont ils sont
presque en prison mais
y'en a beat reggae mon père par exemple
est souvent très gai et très imprévus ça
dépend des gens mais les adultes c'est
les gens qui savent qu'ils sont très
très stable parce qu'ils savent être
drôle tout en ayant en eux ils sont très
bien quoi tandis que nous on sait pas
très bien comment être on n'est pas
fixée je crois que les adultes eux se
sentent très bien oui fait ils ont l'air
sérieux monte règle et comme tu as des
problèmes est que tu parles à tes
parents
non je pense ce donc moyennement à
l'avenir enfin j'essaye de le voir quand
même parce qu'on nous en parle pas mal
mais pour l'instant je vis je vis comme
je suis au jour le jour et je sais pas
de problème et je suis heureuse moi je
la vis à vis très vite
enfin j'ai l'impression qu'elle passe
très vite parce que je m'amuse beaucoup
je sors sans arrêt ge
je vis pleinement jour j'en profite
surtout aux chutes au maximum parce que
je sais qu'il va se terminer dans pas
très longtemps et qu quand elle sera
terminée je pourrai enfin devenir
sérieuses comme comme les adultes et là
je profite de mon adolescence parce que
moi je n'ai rien à regretter
[Musique]